I saw it I've just been feeling really
fortunate that we that all of these
things happen at the same time that
Disney was ready to make this remake at
the time when Hallie Bailey was the age
that she was we are so lucky because who
else could play this part like honestly
spot on she's so incredible she's such a
generational Talent she's so
transformative and then to know her what
an incredible woman she is and as she's
growing up with all of these eyes on her
and all of them the watching the way she
walks of the world she is the person you
want your kids looking up to like if
we're all so lucky that it happened when
it did because it wouldn't what if she
what if they were trying to do it now
and she's able to play the part now I
just I've been feeling so fortunate when
I saw the thing and she was just so
Transcendent and I was just like oh man
we're so lucky